when we hear the word
passive uh you know you think of
something as as being the opposite of
assertive active aggressive
but explain and just
just consider me to be a monkey so
explain how
passive investing is not passive
so just to very quickly define what
people refer to when they
typically talk passive versus active a
passive product is one
whose investment scheme the approach
that it takes to investing
has been built into an index or
into a methodology that does not change
over time and
almost when i refer to passive i'm
referring to things that are
float weighted or market cap weighted
not attempting to make a distinct
bet in terms of what are the best
companies what are the worst companies
etc
right no fundamentals no you don't care
about fundamentals
you are accepting the information that
you're receiving from the market in
terms of the last
price is the right price right
the rationale for passive investing is
tied back to the efficient market
hypothesis which is the idea that as any
individual
you can't outguess everybody else you
can't figure out information
better than everyone else and so in
aggregate
all of the active managers those who are
making active decisions in their
portfolios
will give you the same results as the
passive
exposure because you're buying the
market price and therefore
you're better off going with a passive
investment that can charge lower fees
because it's not actually trying to do
any quote-unquote work it's simply
riding off of everybody else's work
all right the challenge with that
is that if you look at the theoretical
underpinnings of that
model that theoretical model that
passive investing can piggyback on
it's built on the work of a gentleman
called bill sharp who won the nobel
prize in finance
for his work on things like modern
portfolio theory the cap m model
sharp ratios etc and
his paper in 1991 called the arithmetic
of active management
made a very simple declaration of what
passive investing was which is that a
passive investor is one who never
transacts they simply
maintain exposure to the market right
that was the rationale behind it
the problem is is that that doesn't fit
the actual
implementation of passive because when
you think about
somebody who's trying to have exposure
to the market
the only way that you can get that
exposure is by buying or selling
and the minute you do that it makes you
an active investor
you yourself become a participant who
are now
influencing market prices that history
of transactions that i described is what
a market represents or market prices
represent
you've now participated in it you've
joined
that stampede in one form or another and
the perverse aspect of passive investing
is that they are actually the most
motivated players
because they have the world's simplest
algorithms did you give me cash
if so then buy did you ask for cash
if so then sell there's no consideration
in that for what price should i buy at
what valuation should i buy at
should i maybe hold cash for a better
opportunity no
you can't do any of those things your
money is literally
just being forced into the market
regardless of the underlying conditions
so i mean you know to me what you're
describing sounds like
trillions and trillions and trillions of
dollars and we can pop a slide up at
some point where we can see
the growth of indexing which has been
pretty extraordinary
but but what you're describing is
trillions of dollars
of investors putting in a bunch of
orders at the market
which we were told was kind of risky
behavior because that
you were going to get somebody else's uh
price not the price you necessarily
needed to make sure that you got for
your client
but it just sounds like buy at the
market sell at the market
and i mean this can go on until you hit
infinity
so it's not quite that extreme but but
yes and really
you know to simplify yes that is you
know i
in no i do not think that vanguard or
blackrock is behaving
in a irresponsible manner trying to plow
those dollars to work into the market
they are absolutely seeking best
execution within the market i have
complete faith that they're doing that
but what is being fit what people are
failing to consider and what our
research really focuses on is the
cumulative impact
of continual buying with no
consideration for fundamentals
and more importantly actually and this
is where our research is somewhat unique
is that we've focused on the dynamics of
what happens when you transition
between different investor types when
you move away
from the discretionary investor who's
thoughtful about what does valuation
mean
if you fire them and give money to
passive investments that simply assume
whatever price is the right price
you're going to change the market itself
you're actually going to change the way
the market behaves
you're going to change the without the
values at which
uh markets transact you're going to
change the value of cash
right so under an active manager or a
discretionary manager framework
cash can be viewed as a drag but it also
creates extraordinary optionality
because
uniquely among the assets that i hold it
gives me the ability to buy something
without having to sell something else
right optionality you get optionality
when you move to a passive
strategy that holds no cash you lose
that optionality
right and so that's a big chunk of what
you're actually giving up you
effectively are turning cash
into a toxic asset and if we saw this in
the oil market for example
just this year where if you have a toxic
asset
you eventually may be forced to pay
people to get
to take it from you right oil prices
went negative because
nobody could find storage to store this
toxic
product cash is functionally the same to
a passive investor
um so walk us through
why so i'm going to give a good friend
of mine jim bianco i'm not sure if you
know jim but a good friend of mine jim
bianco
um gave me a few statistics this was in
january i was
actually out in your neck of the woods i
was i i was in california at the time at
a double line
event and when we were there he said and
i checked with them this morning the u.s
has
more than 12 000 investment advisory
firms
they employ more than 400 000 people
offering investment advisory services
more than 35 million investors use
investment advisors whose assets
recently topped 70 trillion
88 of investment advisors currently use
or recommend
etfs for their clients no other
investment vehicle has a higher usage
not even
cash yeah so
that's if if i've understood some of
your
prior comments that is not necessarily
there's probably overlap but that is not
necessarily
one in the same that 70 trillion dollar
pile
with 401k investing not at all
and so the the vast majority of 401ks
are actually
managed now within corporations using
out
you know outsourced service providers uh
you know examples would be like voyo
financial or others
right they will offer a limited menu of
investment vehicles
you can choose in many situations to opt
out and self-do what's called
self-direct your 401k
that requires many additional steps in
order to go
through that process and so it's one
that very few people take advantage of
but that tends to be an asset pool that
is separate and distinct from what
you're referring to when you talk about
registered investment advisors
the registered investment advisor space
has been another
area of growth and part of the reason
why that growth has occurred
is the general pressure on fees in this
industry
and that in part can be thought of as a
byproduct of the just the disappearance
of high interest rates right so
you can afford to pay somebody one
percent of your assets or two percent of
your assets
when your cash is earning six percent
right when that hurdle rate is
effectively there when your cash is
earning zero
those costs become very adverse to your
portfolio
and so there's just been tremendous
pressure on fees in the industry both at
the portfolio manager level and the
portfolio management company
level and also at the registered
investment advisor level and so there's
been
an extraordinary adoption of etfs
and index funds that can be offered by
registered investment
advisors at effectively no fees while
they themselves are then able to charge
you know typically a one percent type
fee on their clients assets
and so their clients are getting a
quote-unquote reasonably priced dynamic
but the other thing that you're hitting
on is that this is actually a big
industry it has a lot of people that
work in it those people
are often lambasted for working against
their client interest i'll be honest
with you that's the exception in my
experience rather than the rule the vast
majority of people really do want the
best for their clients
but we've been somewhat hamstrung by the
idea that the industry can't add value
right that effectively like why would
you do anything other than buy the s
p 500 or you know buy the nasdaq right
and part of that i would actually argue
is it is an unfortunate byproduct of
money flowing into those strategies
right so if a market is not frictionless
and money is flowing into a strategy
it's going to raise the price of the
securities that are in that strategy
that increase in price is what we call a
return
right that's a capital gain and so we
actually see outperformance
that is being created by these very
dynamics
the problem of course is what happens
when people try to
exit the system and what are the false
signals that are received on an economic
basis
from prices that are increasingly
detached from fundamentals
um so have there been
any moments in the past few years that
you've seen
stress in the passive space
stress that was maybe quashed but are
there have there been times that you've
kind of seen cracks start to
erupt in the system yes very clearly i
mean so the
the two most obvious ones three most
obvious ones that i would point to and
they tend to be a byproduct of the same
thing that that
you hear me referring to which is
effectively crowded strategies right so
when a strategy becomes crowded it works
great
until people try to get out or an exit
needs to be obtained right and then you
suddenly discover and warn about buffett
lexicon you know who's swimming naked
right right um the
the the events that i would point to um
you know we had actually there's there's
a couple of them but
uh we had the february 2018 event that's
referred to as valmageddon
which was the collapse of the xiv and
related vixx etf strategies
that was one where the size of the short
vol trait associated with the inverse of
the vix the xiv
and related product svxy there were a
couple of them actually
had become so large that it was
completely dominating
the market for what are referred to as
vix futures or ux
futures and when an event occurred that
required
that to be exited on any normal day
those products were taking up 70
of the liquidity when you had a
significant
event that caused a general de-risking
and caused people to try to unwind those
trades
suddenly the requirement for liquidity
jumped to somewhere in the neighborhood
of
a thousand percent of what was actually
available in the market
and exactly as we saw in 1987
transactions just stopped
the market makers stepped away they had
no contractual obligation to do so
and the product was able to fall in an
unconstrained fashion
that then turned around and bled into
the s p itself because people had to
hedge out their exposure to volatility
in one form or another
but that was a very clear example we had
a similar event in the fourth quarter of
2018
where a variety of products also in the
short volatility space what was referred
to as an iron condor type strategy that
was a less risky version of some of the
short vol
that had been in place those began to
unwind
in significant size at the same time
that we began to see the first impacts
in terms of flow
of baby boomer retirements right so when
a
when you hit 70.5 these rules have
changed slightly so it's important to
understand that
but when you hit 70.5 you have to start
taking distributions from your 401ks and
iras
2018 was kind of the first time we
really saw that happen in size and so it
you know a market event was created
around these dynamics
right yeah go ahead and i mean i think
it's just important to
to contextualize what you're what you're
describing right because
uh february the 5th 2018 was j pal's
first day in office and
the dow jones fell over a thousand
points and he was
he was much more of the paul volcker
philosophical
backstopping markets type not you know
not on my watch and
a few days later he gave his first
congressional testimony and said it's
not the fed's job to backstop markets at
which point armageddon went
poof and at the same time
you know as what you're talking about
demographics finally starting to play
out
you'll remember uh you'll remember
because we're coming right up to the two
year anniversary of general electric's
debt being downgraded on halloween
2018 of that year and within 14 days
there was no there was no issuance for
41 days the jungle market
froze so that was a separate illiquidity
event
that it was exacerbated by what you're
describing
going on in the background and of course
led up to christmas eve
yeah and so you know if you if you
remember um
and one of my friends uh a gentleman by
the name of vincent
gillard at fcx stone has just written an
interesting piece that highlights
you know the dates and the dynamics of
when the markets have bottomed on these
last several
events right so the february 5th event
um you know had a recovery off of it and
and
you know you actually um before we move
off of that i actually would highlight
i would actually say that the fed had a
a bigger role
in those events than people are aware of
there was a change to what's called the
c
car provisions right the capital
adequacy provisions
that occurred on february 2nd where they
changed a loophole
that had existed for short vole
positions so the
risk capital that needed to be held
against an equity loan
was set so that um the risk
off event for an equity loan was a
instantaneous 30 decline in the s p 500
right a repeat of the 1987 style events
the equivalent risk in terms of capital
required to hold a short volatility
position
in the vix products was a 10 point
increase in the vix
right now that's those are nowhere near
the same
right that's the equivalent of saying
there is no risk in short vole there's
extraordinary risk in owning equities
guess what happened prior to february
2nd 2018
large short vole positions built up
relative to long equity positions
which of course led people to look at
equity position say oh it's not extended
there's no real risk here etc
but all the risk was actually in the
short vol products
that blew up when those c car provisions
were changed and suddenly the street had
to go out and seek
significant hedging against the
outstanding vol positions
so you know that's the sort of thing
where i would actually say it was much
less passive it was a function of
crowding and a fed
being unaware of what that change that
somewhat obscure change in c-car
provisions might set off
well the the the 59 trading days where
the vix closed in 2017
south of 10 might have been a little bit
of a flag for uh
for for the feds and for regulators in
general but that that's
i i was on the inside and right after
the crisis when they were starting to
you know put extra provisions on banks
at the same time that liquidity was
coming down in the bond market i'm like
you can't combine those two that's like
that ghostbusters scene you're going to
cross the streams don't do it and then
poof the
bond market inventory blip anyways um no
it won't be the last time that
regulators don't quite understand the
plumbing
[Music]